皆さんベイブレード遊んでます動画にはだしないんですけど地図いては異論たさあ2 f
へバクって言って未だに新しいのが出たり買ったりもしてるんですけども
今回ですねベイブレードで絶対負けない方法封筒ついに見つけて背負ったわけですよね
えっうっこれ
[音楽]
ブーバー春風にょ
俺はもうこんな強いのできちゃったの特訓しすぎてもどうしようもないということを
クリックします理由
c 2マンゴーしている
まず黄色ね色
c 2 d e
ています
[音楽]
まあまあ同店で撮ってんだったね勧めで俺負けないって言ったから
私負けないと取ったら勝つぞ3通1号
dj
はいはーい出身者
ザグ不用意な女特有の格子
ていません
tan
アダプワーナーだったし強いね
go 知った
ええええええ
per だった
パワー
はどうして
まあ
ネバーず強い
bar 3 o 2
う少しっ
[音楽]
go can
ポーズアルマが下がる
car
まずません
ああ
ああああああ
tar
ええええええ
ぽんずるーい
th
[音楽]
じゃあこれだってもうこれで負けたらもう最強っていうことがあっていきます
水とぅ1号大
ran
はっはっは
ええええええ
突破言ったら名前最強体協だ何かなんだろう彼方つけてるだけなんだけどね
[音楽]
me
バッハ
バースしないとかよしね一番打ち合いベベルにあるワークをつけたあとはまず動かなく
なったって
[音楽]
初代だ初代に写ってる